so let's talk about texas arizona
another state where we are seeing
movement
toward the purple in texas obviously
that's been at the top of democrats list
the reason that you're target number one
is because they saw that as indicator
that they could finally turn this kind
of deep red state blue
do you think that texas is moving in the
direction of the blue it looks right now
like a lot of folks are moving
into austin a lot of folks moving into
urban areas that are much more to the
left
uh the voting the voting records tend to
show more democratic turnout
is texas in danger of turning purple
absolutely i think texas is a
battleground and you know they're
too broad there are a lot of different
movements going on but two broad
political movements that are
cross-cutting
one thing we're seeing in recent years
is working-class voters
are moving right that's making states
like midwestern states trend more
republican
what we're also seeing however is
suburban voters and particularly
suburban
women are trending left that means
states with big suburban population
states like texas states like georgia
states like arizona
are trending left they're becoming more
purple you know texas people think of
texas
as a rural state you know sort of the
cowboy ethos
but we're one of the most urban and
suburban states in the entire country
three of the ten biggest cities in
america are in the state of texas
and four of the eleven biggest cities in
texas are
in the country are in texas uh in texas
between houston
dallas fort worth austin and san antonio
over two-thirds of the voters in the
state of texas are in those
those four major metro areas we have
massive suburban populations basically
the way the texas voting typically works
is you have the cities which have been
democratic for a while the core of the
cities
and then you've had these bright red
donuts around the cities that have been
suburban republicans that's what's kept
texas solidly republican
but what happened in 2018 is those
bright red donuts became purple
as suburban voters moved heavily left by
the way that's what
decimated the congressional republicans
in in california california has a lot of
suburban
voters as well places like orange county
that used to be very republican and they
moved
significantly to the left if we're going
to stay competitive
we've got to be reaching those suburban
moms and making the case
why these policies matter why why
socialism and open borders
why that is bad for for suburban moms
why that's bad for your kids whether
it's bad for your future
the media doesn't want any of those
messages to get across and and so that
means it's
our job and we've got to do it
in ways that get around the gatekeepers
because the gatekeepers
they're not pretending to be walter
cronkite anymore
they are full-on partisans
they will put on their hat and they will
cheer for whatever leftist wins the
democratic nomination
and they will do everything they can to
collate the information and
and to pitch a propaganda war for those
of us who value freedom we've got to
counteract that